Io sono un avvocato ma oggi non vi
parlerò di leggi o di cose vorrei invece
raccontarvi una storia
parla di innovazione
Ma cosa significa innovazione
si tende a pensare all'inventore come
personaggio di Walt Disney l'amico di
Paperino ricordate A chi mitagorico
una specie di scienziato pazzo che
spaziava dal dischi volanti
personalizzate ai Nasi elettronici per
cercare
nel senso comune l'immagine che si
associa all'idea dell'invenzione quella
di un lampo di genio che faccia il buio
nella realtà le cose non stanno proprio
così io da avvocato mi occupo di gruppi
quindi il tutela così invenzioni dirvi
che nella realtà l'innovazione non
procedo quasi mai per grandi Balzi
inventivi ma il frutto di tante piccole
invenzioni incrementali un'evoluzione
graduale
innovazione È un processo lineare dove
ogni brevetto si poggia sulle spalle del
brevetto precedente un miglioramento
dopo l'altro
sullo stato dell'arte Come si dice in
gergo tecnico quindi l'immagine che
trovo più appropriata quella della
piramide umana del circo in cui ogni
acrobata fare dell'altro per raggiungere
la cima del tendone
Ma se si esce dall'ambito tecnico
scientifico Allora il significato di
innovazione si fa più Rotondo filosofico
innovazione come anticonformismo come
ricerca di nuove modalità per fare le
cose e magari far star meglio le persone
ed è di questo che parla la mia storia
vorrei raccontarvi oggi
nel 2017
il grande studio legale internazionale
che dove tuttora lavoro mi ha chiamata
ad aprire la loro prima vede in Italia
era la prima volta che uccideva in
Italia che fosse una donna sfondare la
figlia italiana di uno di questi grossi
colossi legali internazionali
cosa ha fatto grande sensazione
all'epoca del mio Store addirittura sono
stato intervistata da testate Nazionali
come la Repubblica del sole ma non è di
questo che voglio parlarvi oggi non
voglio raccontarvi la mia esperienza di
avvocato di manager voglio parlarvi di
qualcosa di molto più banale che
sicuramente ciascuno di voi avrà vissuto
L'esperienza di adattarsi a un nuovo
ruolo che sia un nuovo ruolo in famiglia
nella vita privata Nella vita
professionale
come vi dicevo All'epoca ero incinta del
mio secondo bimbo il mio primogenito
aveva appena due anni quindi io a
malapena stavo cominciando ad abituarmi
a conciliare la mia nuova vita da mamma
con il mio lavoro normale di avvocato
che già piuttosto impegnativo quando mi
sono trovata all'improvviso a misurarmi
con questo nuovo ruolo di manager in cui
peraltro Non avevo alcuna preoccupazione
specifica la prima cosa che ho pensato
di fare naturalmente è stata
riorganizzarmi organizzarmi per poter
dopo il parto lavorare da casa
direttamente come se fossi in ufficio
tutto il nostro archivio globale tutti i
dati tutti i documenti dovevano essere
digitali materiali
[Musica]
ora dopo il covid parla l'altro che gli
Smart Working ma all'epoca lo smart
Working era un concetto Qui si guardava
con una certa diffidenza
Era considerato un po' un vento per
donnette casalinghe con un lavoro a metà
un po' ai margini della vita
professionale
impostare uno studio legale in Italia
come stavo facendo Io sradicando
radicando completamente il tabù della
presenza visibile alla scrivania
digitalizzando tutto dando la
possibilità alle persone la flessibilità
di lavorare da casa di essere misurate
in base al raggiungimento di obiettivi e
non in base al numero di ore di lavoro
passati in ufficio
questo lettera rivoluzionario Stiamo
parlando solo di tantissimi anni fa
c'erano dei miei colleghi che stavano
tutta la giornata in ufficio poi
andavano a cena poi tornavano di nuovo
in ufficio dopo cena
Quindi anch'io pur nella mia posizione
ero un po' vittima dello stereotipo Ma
come cazzo sei il capo stare lì a
guardare a controllare a dirigere
no Quando all'improvviso colpo di scena
come sappiamo Nel 2020 succede qualcosa
che nessuno di noi aveva detto mai
immaginato né mai vissuto una pandemia
all'improvviso modalità
la modalità digitale era l'unica
possibile
la mia vita professionale non è cambiata
poi tanto dal punto di vista pratico
dopo lo studio della pandemia Ma chi non
era pronto si è trovato in grave
difficoltà e Tutto all'inizio
la rivoluzione può cogliersi di sorpresa
Se non ti sei già hai voluto prima
il contrario è proprio quella curva
graduale di cambiamento evolutivo
costante a portarti là dove A un certo
punto la rivoluzione possibile
nel filmato della pandemia nel maggio
2020 il nostro nuovo zio globale che
insediato si chiama Justin è uno
scozzese che viveva Hong Kong e ha una
visione molto
globale Naturalmente
una delle prime cose che ha fatto dopo
il festeggiamento è stato è stata
istituire un nuovo gruppo di lavoro si
chiamava
Wolverine
evolviamo il nostro modo di lavorare
trattava di un gruppo multidisciplinare
che comprendeva esponenti di tutte le
funzioni apicali della nostra
multinazionale terzi di business ma
anche di infrastrutture di logistica di
informatica di marketing
anche dei consulenti esterni e anche un
socing rappresentante di ciascuna delle
macroregioni geografiche in cui non
studio è organizzato Anch'io sono stata
invitata a farne parte come Ponente
della regione che chiamiamo
ci siamo riuniti per mesi dal giugno al
dicembre di quell'anno
valutando tanti aspetti aspetti di
business fatti di costo ma anche
psicologici
il risultato è stata abbiamo avuto le
nostre raccomandazioni al Management il
risultato è stata l'adozione a livello
globale di una Policy che consente a
tutti i 27 uffici del mondo studio di
lavorare casa con una modalità ibrida
per almeno il 40% del tempo questo vale
per tutte le risorse di studio qualunque
livello e la nuova normalità
caratterizzerà il nostro modo di
lavorare anche dopo la fine di ogni tipo
di effetto del covi questo nasce dalla
nostra convinzione per cui uno di noi
dal meglio di te al lavoro ma anche
sta meglio dal punto di vista proprio
benessere mentale psicologico sei in
grado il più possibile di
autodeterminarsi
non siamo i soli
quasi tutte le aziende multinazionali
hanno avviato percorsi simili
consapevoli dell'importanza di
raccogliere quella che forse l'unica
eredità positiva di questa pandemia
questa forzata accelerazione della
digitalizzazione dell'Innovazione
qualche anno Forse
del mondo lavorare da casa sarà
addirittura imposto dalle autorità per
salvare No il pianeta contribuire
la morale è che ciò che sembra
eccezionale anti conformista prima può
diventare all'improvviso la normalità a
cui tutti vogliono o devono conformarsi
E allora essere stati innovativi altri
conformisti in prima può portare un
grande vantaggio competitivo dopo
Certo c'è un forte elemento di casualità
come nella teoria dell'evoluzione di
Darwin
le mutazioni genetiche vengono
casualmente non è l'ambiente a
determinarle
ma è l'ambiente a selezionare quelle che
sono le migliori per l'evoluzione per la
sopravvivenza
allo stesso modo nessuno di noi può
predire il futuro e sapere dove porta
l'innovazione
penso un esempio vicino a me l'esempio
della ricerca farmacia
si stima per ogni molecola che arriva
sul mercato e diventa un farmaco
efficace sicuro portare magari una
malattia fino ad allora prima di cura ve
ne siano almeno 10.000 che non ce la
fanno ovvero non superano gli studi
clinici
chi lavora nei dipartimenti di ricerca e
sviluppo del grande società
farmaceutiche sa come funziona ci sono
tanti tentativi infruttuosi fino a
quando c'è un colpo di fortuna qualcosa
di inatteso succede si arriva che giunge
un invenzione interessante
che
tra l'altro come vi dicevo prima io da
avvocato mi occupo di
contenziosi concerti in questi discute
della validità siamo un ragazzo sia o
meno Più o meno valido Sapete qual è il
brevetto più valido più forte proprio
quello in cui L'invenzione Era in attesa
in cui il ricercatore che è arrivato
Mentre stava facendo altro
che è un po' una saggezza della nonna la
vita quello che succede facendo altri
programmi
è una situazione di John Lennon in
realtà una delle mie ferite
quindi dicevamo della casualità mentre
io mi stavo organizzando il mio ufficio
Smart Working Milano naturalmente non mi
stavo attrezzando Casomai arrivate so
una pandemia
stavo facendo soltanto il mio personale
percorso di evoluzione di adattamento
adattamento per me a conciliare due cose
contemporaneamente l'arrivo del mio
secondo bimbo e del mio terzo figlio che
lo studio che ho aperto che poi diciamo
una graficamente sono fratelli gemelli
stavo cercando di costruire un nuovo
ambiente di lavoro che nella mia visione
sarebbe stato diverso dallo studio
legale tradizionale che mi sembrava più
congeniale a me ma soprattutto un posto
dove le persone potessero stare meglio
lavorare meglio
tutto poi l'ambiente la congiuntura
casualmente da far sì che col mio sia
diventato quello a cui tutti si sono
dovuti adeguare dopo
l'evoluzione un po' sorpresa Se non ti
sei già hai voluto prima
Per quanto possa sembrare anche
intuitivo quindi l'innovazione è un
metodo va applicato con costanza
questo vale per tutto
tutti voi qualunque cosa facciate
chiunque siate sono sicura che mille
volte che sarete trovati in una
situazione in cui siete detti poteva
esserci un modo migliore magari più
efficiente di fare una certa cosa
ma magari non sempre Avete provato a
suggerirlo questo modo migliore e
provato a innescare il cambiamento
magari certe volte avrete lasciato
perdere perché avrete sarà venuto il
dubbio può esservi venuto il dubbio che
non ne valesse nemmeno la pena che non
fosse possibile
Ecco io credo che nel dubbio valga
sempre la pena per darci i determinati a
seguire le proprie convinzioni anche
quando sei i primi ti viene guardato un
po' male
bisogna avere fiducia in noi stessi e
nelle nostre convinzioni
Nella peggiore delle ipotesi
avevano fatto qualcosa di buono per noi
stessi ci sentiremo un po' più padroni
Delle nostre scelte
saranno guadagnati un pochettino in più
di libertà e di benessere
Se siamo fortunati poi magari il mondo
si adeguirà a noi
magari ci metterà dieci anni
magari
cedere che un evento del tutto
eccezionale e imprevedibile fare gli a
tutto
E allora cambiamento che sarebbe
avvenuto in dieci anni Viene in 10
giorni
e non è più evoluzione quella
rivoluzione
e noi ci troveremo all'avanguardia di
quella rivoluzione